now last time you were here you
proclaimed rather proudly that you had
kicked
pot marijuana you had stopped completely
how's that going for you it kicked me
back
now is it true that pharrell he was the
one encouraging you to be a bit more
family-friendly yeah yeah he
made me change certain words i had a
song called so many hoes he made so many
pros
crews just prostitutes
no they're professionals oh i see
that was a tough loss um how do you feel
after that how the [ __ ] you think i feel
ask no dumb ass questions
get get it all out get it off i don't
feel like [ __ ] right now
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you think of my life and feel
amazing i take a loss i mean yeah
so who do you think is gonna take the
victory don't give a [ __ ] stop asking
all these dumb ass questions we lost
like hey you interview now be gone
playing the uh huggy bear part just
seemed like perfect yeah and and you do
a great job in this role how did this
happen he was considering me for huggy
bear with a couple other people and i
was telling him i was like look man
give me the spot that's me i'm huggy
bear they can't do it like i can do it
and once i talk to him i just put it out
in the public and let everybody know
that was my part he couldn't do nothing
but give it to me
you stole a tv dog from b-e-t
so you know what this was around the
time when bt wasn't playing my videos
and they was
they was acting real funny so
i had to send a message to the top to
let them know i wasn't playing
what
was it was it uh
was it an 18 inch or what kind of tv was
it back it was probably like about a 19
inch flat screen the homie put it up on
his jacket and we made him look this way
and we walked out that way
you just put it in the car took off put
it in the back seat like a human and
rolled off with it
i mean this middle you would pay that
has anyone paid 99 dollars just for the
image that's how the gold that's how the
image is on your face your people from
your show paid nothing what
idiots and you're talking about you know
the devil something uh the devil will
show up but we're continuing to do god's
work do you believe in the devil
definitely what do you think the devil
is like
president
the mtv
wanted you to do an osborne's type
reality show
behind the scenes you your family is
that true yeah
and i passed on it because i didn't i
didn't want them to be all in my life
like this 24 hours a day i think they
get on my nerves and one of them
cameraman they end up getting f'ed up
i believe she is uh wha what is that
that's uh alaska right where she's from
again alaska okay so is she alaskan or
she american
[Music]
oh you [ __ ] me up on that one i don't
know
i don't know
you were pimping you know you don't love
them hoes that [ __ ] was tight but you
know what else said that that was tight
me 15 years before you did it stop
biting my
i'm you're five hours late here man shut
the [ __ ] up come on man no we just saw
you on twitter
five hours late [ __ ] i'm here [ __ ] be
happy i'm here and ask some real
questions yeah i was just wondering what
you what you know why you were so late
and i saw you were twittering about
stopped me being stuffed at the porter i
was late because i went to go get some
chicken wings that's why i was late they
have a walk of fame in russia yeah they
do i didn't know that yeah it's only
three people on it
who who's on it paris hilton sylvester
stallone and me
when you're they tell you like hey we'd
love to have you on the family feud and
you say okay i'll do it how do you pick
which members of your family get to go
and be on it with you the smartest ones
the smartest ones if i could work with
anybody dead or alive i'd want to work
with um uh
maybe gandhi
okay gandhi was the [ __ ]
yeah
[Laughter]
the atlanta braves brought home their
first championship in 26 years
over a million people turned off for the
parade and after waiting three hours for
it to start
this is what they saw
[Music]
[Laughter]
that may be the funniest clip that we've
seen all day
they going like
35. do they know what a parade park
what do they tell the drivers no matter
what under no conditions do you slow
this [ __ ] down
you have over 10 million twitter
followers but you were slow to embrace
twitter is that right you you didn't
respect it because i didn't understand
what it was everybody was saying i'm
following you i'm following like were
you following me too
and then i finally i got a hold of it
that sounds paranoid
[Laughter]
why would you be paranoid i mean
who are your top three greatest rappers
of all time
slick rick
ice cube
[Applause]
socks i just put on look at this right
here
damn it
my feet cold i gotta hold this big head
ass baby and walk through here
hold us
man
[Laughter]
[Music]
my bones
[Music]
uh
i was coming to do a little show and the
old dude like about 70 something years
old he was like i've been waiting all
day can i have your autograph so i gave
it to him he was like for shizzle my
nestle
and then he died
i never seen the gator get punked by no
mongooses
retreat yeah retreat yeah back up
yeah we them boys hey hold
[Applause]
great i need some tissue i've been
crying my eyes are flying hold on we got
some pick-up questions we're gonna do a
goddamn my eyes is water you want me to
be crying on tv
grab me some tissue card real quick like
this [ __ ] called continuity ain't that
what your word y'all like using you
you've marketed a car you could actually
buy a car yeah snoop de ville the snoop
devil
and now you're coming out with a
barbecue grill is that right
[Applause]
i called him
and i said uh can you feature on my song
and he said like what is the title of
the song and i said hang over and he
said i'm doing it
have you uh have you hung out in in
canada much oh yeah after that i went
and shot a video out there um
went out there for a few basketball
games i love it out there they're
speaking english but you know they say
like a and things like that were you
were you picking up on that when you
were up there i didn't pick up no a but
i picked up the green
makes a straight [ __ ] you could tell
to what they're looking at
they plotting right now see how they got
their necks up that means they're coming
to get it
the lizards don't even see what's
happening but you understand me one
thing about a lizard i think he had
geico
if he had geico he got a 15 percent
chance of making up out of here i think
you're blacker than barkley everybody
thinks that you are everybody
right i think they do
all week so we sent the sample of your
dna to the dna diagnostic center in
cincinnati
and i have your results snoop
are you ready i'm ready i'm also ready
snoop dogg
you are zero percent east asian
wait a minute i don't got no asian in me
i like chinese food
[Applause]
snoop you are 23
native american
that's that's pretty big that's real big
it only leaves 77 percent left
you are six percent european
so what does that mean hang on
the moment we've all been waiting for
charles barkley is 75 sub-saharan
african aka black
drum roll please
snoop dogg you are 71
sub-saharan advocate
oh my god snoop
charles barkley is blacker than you are
oh no
charles barkley got your ass by four
percent oh no
i want to feel like george bush right
now we got to have a re-vote this ain't
right
this ain't right